[Music]
steve is with us steve's in lansing
michigan hi steve how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
okay uh well my wife and i are
what seemed seems like an impossibly
tight spot uh we've uh we've been
dealing with uh
basically uh increasing health problems
and income reduction
and right now we're kind of in a spot
where we feel like we need
uh you know like an unrealistic
financial miracle that we know won't
happen
uh so that that's kind of the situation
we're in
okay let's talk that through and
understand what you're talking about
okay what is your income what are your
incomes
okay um we we were at about 74 30 a
month and it has we have been reduced to
about 3 200. i'm a paraplegic i've
always worked um
but my work has completely dried up over
this past year with kovid and a few
things and then her income was reduced
and she has lost her health insurance so
like i said we go from 74 30 to 3 200 a
month we've had some big home and
vehicle repairs that are necessary and
we're going through total money makeover
we realized that we weren't there for
that so we uh kind of dialed it back and
went we're going through financial peace
and
we realized we're still not even quite
there so we really need some direction
on what to do with this
situation so what are you doing for work
right now
right now i'm a freelance web developer
and
technology and
kind of a small business
small business has been my main
clientele and that has largely
evaporated could you look for a salaried
position
with a company i
yes yeah i'm i'm in the process of
trying to do that i am not
i have not been successful uh thus far
with that
okay
help me with this because web developers
are in great demand
when you say you're a web developer what
do you what do you mean you're a dev1
dev2 dev3
what are your platform architect what do
you do
yeah i do yeah well i basically i just
do
i'm kind of a jack-of-all-trades i am uh
i do
i create
sites for you know small businesses i
work with their marketing i do just try
to to set up uh
new businesses with an entire
just their entire
initial setup do you have the skills to
join a dev team
probably not okay that's what i was
hearing probably not to be honest okay
all right
because that obviously the dev the bit
the developer world is is just in great
demand right now we've got a
several hundred of them on our team and
are constantly hiring in that spot and
so that's the only reason i've got a
little bit of knowledge about it is it's
a frustration point here at ramsey so uh
if but if you can so you really need to
get your business moving of helping
small businesses or get involved with
somebody who's doing that like a
marketing agency or something that would
hire you to help with the with the
technology side of a marketing campaign
yeah so yeah something like that would
would be would be wonderful i've had
a big private like i said is
what were you doing who were you with
before how were you how were you making
money before
uh word of mouth uh online
uh
some some small online marketing uh and
just you had multiple clients
yes
yes
okay were they in a space that were shut
down with covet or what
yeah um yeah
i had four major i wouldn't say major my
four primary clients and all of them uh
dried up over the course of the last
year and a half
okay every single one shut down there
okay all right
well the good news is you're not
geographically bound with what you're
doing you could do it you you can reach
out online and you could be doing it for
someone in nashville you could be doing
it for someone i mean if lansing is not
operating as openly as some other areas
you could get that going so i think
you've got a marketing problem on your
side and and you're probably your
miracle in that regard how much of the
74 30 were you making
uh
let's see 74
um hold on
i got my numbers here probably
over half was about 40
let's see
32 okay i was about 42. yeah it feels
like you guys have an income crisis that
is creating these other crises
and just in talking to you for a moment
here that's what it feels like and it
feels like you guys got to get
uh
you you've had all these things happen
to you
and you've got to turn the tables and
start happening to
the situation let me send you a copy of
ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose and jump on his website start
studying things i'll also send you a
copy of the entree leadership book since
you're running your own thing because i
really want to give you guys a boost on
the income side of the equation i think
that's going to solve where you're going